pues esta alerta publicada en el boletín
nacional de terrorismo lo que dice es
que hay personas extremistas impulsadas
por este sentimiento anti gobierno
impulsadas también y potencializadas por
la toma al capitolio que estarían
enfocadas en generar ataques violentos
contra símbolos del gobierno edificios
gubernamentales o personas que estén en
contra de los simpatizantes de donald
trump y las ideologías extremistas hay
que resaltar también que esta noticia se
conoce justo después de que se conociera
que enriqueta rió el cubanoamericano que
lidera el movimiento extremista de los
productores en eeuu pues fue es
informante los revela writers es
informante de los organismos de
inteligencia de eeuu como se está
protegiendo el gobierno de bailén y que
medidas preventivas ha tomado para
evitar nuevos ataques como los del 6 de
enero
de hecho ya 150 personas fueron
arrestadas estas personas habían estado
involucradas en la toma del capitolio y
harían parte de otros grupos extremistas
como los twitters centers o los
outfitters además el yo bailé en el
propio presidente ha dicho que de los 25
mil hombres de la guardia nacional que
estaban presentes el día de la
inauguración va a dejar en washington
5000 hombres de la guardia nacional que
se ven por las calles de la ciudad
precisamente evitando cualquier tipo de
amenaza de violencia por parte de algún
grupo extremista al gobierno de alguien
también está empujando para que con
prontitud se apruebe se ha confirmado
alejandro mayorkas que va a ser
precisamente el secretario de seguridad
nacional de seguridad interior que
liderará el que quiere empujar con el
fbi y con otros organismos de
inteligencia la estrategia para evitar
estos a esta potencia la amenaza de
ataques terroristas domésticos resto al
vázquez muchas gracias por tu reporte
desde washington